hello my name is Caleb Denby and welcome
back to brain review today we're gonna
be taking a look at one of my own games
between myself and Isaiah Gadson so in
this game between myself and Isaiah I
played d4 he played g6 I played c4
he played Bishop g7 this is a very
tricky move order I'm very upset when my
opponents play this move order because
they want me to play Knight c3 and they
want to pretend they're gonna play c5
and after d5 they're gonna take this
Knight now this line isn't actually
super great for black white should have
an advantage but I've never bothered to
learn it so to avoid this line I change
up my move order just a bit play Knight
f3 first guarding these squares not
putting my knight on the square where it
can be captured black responds with
Knight f6 and now after Knight c3 I
don't have to worry about this knowing
line so black plays d6 I play e4 black
castles Bishop e2 'if five castles and
we have achieved the main line of the
Kings Indian defense the classical
variation so now black is a few options
here the main line by far is actually
knight c6 and after d5 this Knight will
retreat black tries to checkmate me over
here I try to win over on the Queen side
it's your classical Kings Indian in the
game though black chose a little bit of
a more sidelines with 9b d7 and in this
case black puts less pressure on my
center so I don't feel the need to play
d5 quite so early on in fact I simply
played Bishop e3 here adding even more
support to the center now black has
quite a few options here we can play c6
to complete our key eight and in the
game black chose Knight g4 trying to
highlight that my bishop can't actually
stay on this e3 square I come out to
Bishop F or Bishop g5 and now that main
move f6 was played in the game and so
what his white achieved with this
maneuver well white has drawn this pawn
to the f6 square it's not going to be so
easy for this night to come back to the
very natural square on f6 now after f6
White has a few options actually you can
drop the bishop back on the Kings side I
don't really like this choice because
the bishop feels like it gets a little
bit out of play on the Kings side as
always in the King's in
white is looking to gain space on the
Queen side of the board and so with a
bishop drop back to h4 you can't really
use this Bishop to support these ideas
over here the mutt perhaps the most
natural move is Bishop c1 but I don't
like this move either because it
interferes with the whites mate with
whites major pieces and so the move I
picked was actually the most unnatural
looking move to my eyes it's Bishop d2
with this move you keep the coordination
on the first rank between all of these
major pieces you actually support some
Queen side pushes with b4 as well so
after Bishop d2 my opponent played the
move Knight age six rerouting this night
to a natural square on f7 and in the
game I was trying to think of the way to
make the most use out of this Bishop on
d2 and I said that was with the move D
takes e5 so after D takes e5 black
recaptures and thanks to this Bishop I
can now play the move b4 quite naturally
blacks natural response to b4 is a five
but thanks to this Bishop not being on
c1 I can respond to this with a three
and maintain my control over these dark
squares black responded with Knight f7
and I wanted to talk it just a little
bit about the importance of this move b4
if I don't play b4 here and I play
another natural move like Queen c2 well
now black has this option to play Knight
c5 and kind of reroute this Knight into
the d4 square this is why I wanted to
play B for so early on in the game but
of course before prevents that so we see
knight of seven now I continue with c5
taking even more Queen side space and
black plays c6 keeping this Knight out
of the d5 square for the moment Queen b3
was my choice getting on this open
diagonal and clearing the pathway for a
rook to come d1 we saw Queen e7 I
actually bring this Bishop back to e3
now this Knight can no longer jump to g4
to harass me rook d8 I challenged the
rook with rip d1 no not f8 from black I
played rook takes d8 Queen takes d8 and
rook back to d1 just taking advantage of
this open file in the temporary miss are
on
coordination of the black pieces to gain
control this file gained a temple on the
Queen and now the key move here for
white I think is this move that I played
in the game b5 this is how you break
through on the Queen side take advantage
of your extra space well I continued
with Bishop e6 but now I simply play
Queen a4 and black came up with this
move Knight d8 to defend the c6 square
which is a little bit awkward to say the
least I captured on c6 black captures on
c6 I simply reroute this Knight back
through d2 to support my pawn on c5
black plays in 97 this lets me simply
play knight b3 and I am supporting this
pawn quite naturally now in the game
perhaps black should have continued now
with f5 trying to open up this Bishop a
little bit put some more pressure on the
the center and the King side of the
board instead he tried to meet me on the
Queen side and the problem with that is
that White has more space here and if
you have more space on the side of the
board then you should in theory at least
be stronger on that side of the board in
the game my opponent played bishop f8
trying to create more threats against my
c5 pawn he wants to come through with
Knight be 7 even just totally trying to
break through on the sieve now
unfortunately for black this actually
allows white to play a pretty
interesting move I'll let you at home
try to find the move this is the only
move to kind of get a winning advantage
here with the white pieces and if you're
a fan of the game review series you
might have already seen a similar idea
in a game between mission odd and wang
hao of course the move I'm talking about
is Knight to d5 sacrificing this Knight
for one pawn but allowing yourself to
have a very mobile pawn center to take
advantage of the displacement of the
black pieces my opponent accepted the
sacrifice with C takes d5
he takes d5 and went with Bishop f5 now
unfortunately for black there's one move
that just completely shuts them out of
the game that move of course is g4
forcing this bishop off of this diagonal
where it controls some very key square
the bishop would have to step to see too
but now d6 Queen f7 is forced to stop it
in Annoying check and now simply Bishop
c4 96 and after rook d2 this game is
gonna be over quite soon
just for example here Bishop e4 loses a
piece to take some takes so if you take
on b3 well now you get hit with Queen
takes b3 and the pressure on this
diagonal mixed with the pressure of
these pawns it's just going to win the
game unfortunately though I missed this
move g4 I'm not that good at chess
so I played d6 instead after Queen e8
black is very much trying to hold on
I played Bishop b5 still adding pressure
on this diagonal Knight f7 was my
opponent's choice now I break through
with c6 this Knight comes to b6 takes
takes and now there are some tactics
here which do allow me to regain the
piece d7 and you can't really get away
with Queen d8 or I'll still get hit with
c7 when I'm going to be winning your
rook
so black simply took on d7 C takes D 7
and now Queen D 8 and I move my Queen
off of this open file in this case
though white does still have a little
bit of an edge but it's nothing compared
to the edge that I would have had with
g4 black played King g7 a very nice move
stepping off of this annoying diagonal I
simply played Queen d5 trying to get
some threats on the King side 96 was my
opponent's choice forcing this bishop to
c6 now rook b8 is a nice move you need
to keep an eye on this back rank or else
you might get into trouble and the move
I came up with here is a 4 trying to
break down this pawn so I can get my
last piece into the action Knight f7
from black is a nice choice just trying
to free up this Queen a little bit and
get this Knight to blockade the d8 pond
or the d7 pawn in this case in the game
I played Knight d2 preparing to reroute
this Knight to some better squares Queen
e7 and now I really kind of mess up the
game here I should have played a move
like rook b1 or rook c1 with the idea
being after
like Queens c5 I can simply take this
and after takes breakthrough with the
move a5 and this would have been really
nice for white here it's tough to stop
this pawn from getting all the way up
the board instead though I wasted some
time with the move Knight c4 now after
Queen c5 I still tried to move rook b1
but 98 is forcing the Queen's off the
board after takes takes and Bishop d5
and now this is more of the same but I'm
actually just down a few Tempe here King
f8 I break through with rook b5 first
and after king e7 a five but the similar
idea unfortunately for me though after
King takes d7
I can't just promote this pawn thanks to
the move knight c6 for black so I kind
of had to switch tactics here played
Knight takes b6 perhaps it takes me six
was fighting for more of an edge I chose
to take these pieces off the board
though and now it is four versus four
but this B pawn can be rather annoying
for black my opponent played very
accurately here under severe time
pressure which was impressive to me I
was kind of hoping if it just messed up
in the game would end but Knight b7 is
totally correct
I played G for giving my King some space
and kind of hampering these puns 96 from
black I played it rook b4 now Knight CA
is already putting pressure on this pawn
I play b7 the knight comes back to d6
now and the pressure is renewed rook v6
was my idea perhaps I had a chance to
gain an advantage without playing Rick
b6 by playing rook b3 with an idea we'll
take a look at a little bit later on in
the game instead the Rick b6 and after
king c7 I came up with rook a6 trying to
keep pressure on the F pawn the fact is
though black should probably just take
this pawn and accept that he's gonna be
slightly worse in this endgame where
these pawns are a little bit fractured
he will have 96 and perhaps white can
play for a win here but it should
theoretically be drawn in the game
though my opponent didn't like this idea
he played rook f8 trying to hold on to
everything this allows Rick c6 check
King d7 and now the move rook c3 is the
winning idea for white
why should I think have a winning
advantage here rook b8 is what my
opponent tried but now the idea is the
same ideas Rick b3 you hop over to this
h-file and there's no comfortable way to
defend this Age pawn perhaps the best
you can do is just try and hold on with
King c7 but now after Rick takes h7 king
b6 and h4 there's gonna be passed pawns
on both sides of the board and black
will be unable to defend in the game
though my opponent was in very severe
time pressure and he's simply blundered
in this case with hurricane a now of
course the last move of the game the
winning move is rook takes h7 forking
the king in the rook mister cannot be
captured due to be eight Queens
when white is simply just winning so
this was a very nice game I think but by
both me and my opponent I was quite
proud of this game actually if you allow
a little Vandy I like this 95 idea for
white and shows you how to play with
this mobile pawn center you have some
interesting concept or interesting piece
sacrifices to make use of the pawn
Center and use your space advantage to
crush your opponent meanwhile my
opponent played very well under a lot of
pressure under time pressure as well and
the game perhaps was drawn at a moment
there in the endgame but unfortunately
for him in time pressure he did it
eventually slip up and I managed to win
the game
oh that's all for this episode of game
review thank you very much for joining
me my name is Caleb Ben B and I'll see
you next time